should you start a short film by writing
a log line I like writing a log line
first to say what in the world is your
short film even if you don't think
you're going to have it written down
when you talk to people about having
them be part of your film they're going
to say what's your film about right so
you should have a log line that can tell
people what your film is and if you
write it ahead of time and have it ready
to spew and say easily then that is
really a good thing but ultimately
you're gonna have to tell people what
your film is about whatsoever when you
finish your film and if you want to put
it online or send it out in the festival
circuit you have to write a long line
that gets sent with that film and that
log line they print verbatim so one of
the short films I produced uh was a film
called I'm on fire and it's about a guy
who's on fire we had special effects to
put them on fire so the filmmaker wrote
The Log line and we're like what the
hell is the log line going to be for
this because you know before he comes
out in theory you don't know he's gonna
be on fire and then he's on fire
um so the filmmaker came up to log on
with a very short film about a man on
fire
pretty much said what it was and it was
it was like two minutes long it's a very
short film about a man on fire so to
this day I can easily quote that log
line because it is that's what the film
is about so
um but yeah your log line is going to
follow that film on IMDb everywhere in
the world so you want to make sure you
write it well but also you don't want to
write it so obscurely that people are
like I have no idea you know because I'm
on fire it could be a manifestation of
Love told in a unique way and I want to
be it's that film about the Man on Fire
you know it's like that's what it is the
title is that speaking of blocklines
titles are also super important for
short films and I love a unique title
because again marketing is going to be
something you need to think about and so
uh you know are you gonna hashtag it are
you going to be a way that people can
find it but there's so many short films
that just have a generic short title
that means nothing and you can't you
know there's a hundred of those films
and uh you know I'm trying to think of a
oh well I have a friend that did a film
called Pig and that's a good title and
you you know there's not that many films
called pigs so we can find it easily in
that way but if you do a long title you
could totally do a long title too I
always tell people a short film it's
never going to be on Marquee somewhere
so you can do a super long title if you
want although people will always kind of
shorten it when they tell you what the
version of it is but I love a unique
title I think that also shows your
creativity and the specialness of the
film it makes people interested we also
produced a short film called 78 and it
was about a kid on a manhole cover
jumping up and down and up and down it
keeps on saying 78 78 78 and so um the
film is called 78 and people would say
to us in the festival circuit they'd see
the filmmaker having watched the film
before and they're like 78 78 78 it's
like how nice look at they're quoting
the title and they remember that from
the film and there you go so you know
yeah if your film is about a man on fire
I'm on fire is not a bad title for it
and uh people kind of know what it is so
writing a good long line totally counts
and you should spend time into it it's
also if you write a really complicated
log line that is hard to follow or it's
too obscure you can write it and they'll
publicize it but nobody's gonna call it
that Thunder Road is a short film that
was it's a terrific short film people
love Thunderbird interesting enough also
versus spring title as this I'm on fire
but anyway
um oh yeah that's true yeah uh Thunder
Road when I looked at his official log
line
um for it's about a Cop who's uh um
giving a eulogy about his dead mother
um so that's my log line for it his log
line is it is um officer Arnold loves
his mother
what okay okay doesn't mention funeral
or eulogy which is a big part of that
short film but that's the log line that
he wrote for it but when most people say
about they're like it's that one about
the cop giving the eulogy about the mom
so your film boils down to what the
essence is no matter how much you try to
dress it up and do different things with
it
pig is that Nicholas Cage's movie Pig no
pig is oh because it's a terrific film
um it's a it's a genre of urban myths so
here I'll tell you the story of pigs
often when people sell stories um so
it's a woman in a Mercedes driving down
a uh and she's super fancy she's driving
down this windy road and coming up from
the opposite direction no she's coming
up and he's going down
um coming down the phenomous and
direction is a really gross guide of
best bunnies picking his nose and he's
totally he's like a pig right and so
when she passes him she yells out of the
window at a pig when we've seen him
doing specifically gross things and then
um we we don't see it but we hear a
crash and the move head Falls over and a
pig crosses the road so she was warning
him that there was going to be a kid
it's terrific and people laugh and laugh
and laugh when it's online too you can
see it online they laugh and laugh and
laugh when they're just not expecting to
see an actual real pig and she and so
the twist was she wasn't calling him a
pig she was warning him that there was a
pig at the end of the road that's
fascinating so there's a payoff a great
payoff and we don't see her get do we
see her getting into her car or she's
just already in already driving okay
great so we've we've kind of cut to the
chase in that part exactly and then I
guess do you would they call it muddy
middles where we just kind of like don't
have enough that's clear-cut in the
middle does that happen with short films
it does it you know beginning is so
important ending is so important so then
we're like well what about the middle
the middle is so important too isn't
that terrible at every single part
counts but yeah the middle is really
tricky and sometimes people put too much
in the middle and we've kind of lost the
thread of what's going on
um or they don't put enough in the
middle and it's kind of like you had a
great beginning and a great end but we
don't really there was no middle to make
it really work so the middle is where
people fall apart too Beginnings middles
and ends
all important does a short film have to
have a hook
feature films and short films benefit
from having a hook and filmmakers hate
to hear that they're like I don't want
to do something crassic commercial and
something that has a hook but hook just
means is there's something we know what
it is and the hook sometimes can be
genre
um but it's so much easier if there is
some kind of quick way that we can say
what this piece is about without
destroying what it is you know obviously
you don't want to give it all away with
and that's where log lines are tricky if
the hook is something that is given away
you have to craft around so that people
don't know what that twist is going to
be
um but it really does help to have a
hook and it also shows you have kind of
a a good storytelling sense and people
like that and so they're like this
person knows how to deliver something
that really hooks the audience and um is
commercially kind of in that sense it's
not in my world it's not a negative
thing I'm coming from someone who's from
Hollywood so you know maybe the NYU
filmmakers are the Columbia filmmakers
are like hook no don't even talk about
the world hook but you know to me hook
is not a negative thing it really is
um it gives you a hook for
so we made a short film called I'm on
fire it was about a guy on fire that's
the hook right now there's a story that
happens there and I'm not telling you
about that story but
I say to you it's a film about a guy on
fire would you like to see a short film
about a guy on fire
hopefully people say yes yeah I'm
interested to see what happens then what
happens is what's going to I've hooked
you into wanting you to make you want to
see it but what why you would like it
and tell other people about it is
because there's a story that you like in
it well with PEG what was what's the
hook the hook is that you think that
it's going to be
um uh that he's a pig and the trans the
switches that oh no there's an actual
Pig at the end I see okay right right so
the the hook is like sort of diverting
the audience's attention in a sense
actually though I'll tell you the hook
of that is kind of like it's an urban
myth or it's a joke so you know she's uh
dramatized something that is a urban
myth I see okay so typical sort of
Hollywood and disdain and then you find
out oh no there's an actual animal
that's Crossing okay right well Thunder
Road is a terrific short film and it's
about a guy who's doing a yoga for his
mom that's the the hook I guess would be
that he's doing usually for his mom the
actual not the room on the short film
for people but he actually starts
singing along to the song Thunder Road
and so it's very um heartfelt and yet
tricky and weird and uh
um it's a delightful short film but so
you know is the hook like it's eulogy is
the hook that he actually does a dance
and sings along to the song Thunder Road
there's two hooks maybe it also is a
One-Shot film too so is that the hook
that we've done a One-Shot film
and with short films you can do these
really weird things too like the hook is
that it's all shot with security cameras
you know or it's all shot with a drone
or the hook could be we shot this in
IMAX format
um so sometimes it can be the format it
can also be like um the hook is a vlog
that is being dramatized that's the hook
for it sometimes it's the storyline that
it is
um also a format I love is a
mockumentary and so the hook there is
that we're kind of thinking taking you
out to thinking it's like a real
documentary but it's really a
mockumentary
um there's so many terrific hooks with
short films primarily because they have
to be about something
so
there's a terrific documentary I love
that was part of the New York op docs
called pickle and so pickle is the
world's worst title right pickle is it
gonna be about a pickle maker whatever
turns out pickle is the name of a fish
and it's about this couple that have all
these uh pets that have something wrong
with them and I can't remember what was
wrong with pickle but maybe couldn't
swim or something like that
um so it's a very very Charming doc
about this couple that have pets that
have all these problems so
um that's kind of the hook of what the
film is but it's so touching and so um
moving and uh but yeah pickle is a
terrible name for it how much conflict
do you need for a short film conflict
and drama is everything in storytelling
right so I think you have to have it in
a short film as well and by conflict I
think it just means
um tension right so you could have one
person be in the entire film but as long
as there's some kind of tension in what
the storytelling or the situation is you
don't have to have two people you know
battling or something like that when we
mean conflict I think it really just
means tension or tight storytelling
um and that's what moves things along so
I think for feature films boy conflict
is essential for everything for a short
film you can Define What conflict means
to you but we uh we want it tight and so
sometimes you know why it films 20
minutes long and it's just you feel like
there's nothing going on let's tighten
it and find where the conflict is in it
right let's just go for the parts that
are dramatic and storytelling and leave
out the stuff that seems to be
um extraneous and just character but it
gives them characters like we don't have
time for character in this we gotta go
for what what's the conflict here what's
going on here how much do antagonists
factor to short films so for feature
film it's like the protagonist and the
antagonist for short it's great if you
can do a protagonist and antagonist but
there's no reason that you absolutely
have to do that it could be that might
not be the story that you're telling uh
it could I've seen a lot of great short
films that have one person is the story
so you know where is your antagonist in
there the antagonist could be something
like time you know or it doesn't have to
be a person per se that is battling the
protagonist the protagonist has
something that they're working through
or whatever so it's not like features
that we need to have you know the
protagonist and the antagonists and they
have their low point and their High
Point and then the antagonist learns at
the end of the protagonist learns and no
for a short film you really don't need
to do that but I think it's more
interesting if there is something that
your hero is dealing with
do main characters in short films have
goals so in a feature film yeah you
definitely want to have a goal you know
that's always like what's their uh want
and their need and what are they trying
to do for short films I do think quite
often to follow along you kind of assume
that you're going to this person who
doesn't even need to be a person right
it could be a dog or something like that
is your lead character but your lead
character is trying to do something or
something is happening to that person
and then we'll feel satisfied at the end
when it is complete but it isn't like
the the um you know the myth tell Joseph
Campbell's myths or something like that
with the short film you know your
favorite film could be two minutes long
it's pretty hard to do seven stages of
the tahiro's journey or whatever in two
minutes long and that should be a
feature you know like if you're trying
to do that
maybe move it on to the feature part of
it for this one let's just do the
training sequence or something like that
so uh you know I think every character
it's great to have some sort of goal um
it might not be as complex of a goal or
as deep as a goal it could be totally
just as little as much as like trying to
figure out what's going on here or
whatever
backstory should you write into the film
I think as much as you as the writer of
the film you should put all your effort
into as many ways as you can right and
so and actors want to know about all
this backstory so nobody's going to stop
you from doing all of that but you don't
necessarily need to put it into what we
actually see on screen it could be all
this information that helps that
character be unique when we see them on
screen so you know you don't you could
do backstory like he loves bowling so
when I'm gonna dress him I'm gonna have
him dress in the bowling shirt but I
don't need to see him in the bowling
alley because this is about a story
about you know when he murdered his
mother or whatever
um so you know you want to uh it's great
to have all that backstory stuff in it
but unlike a feature we don't have to
see a lot of it actually manifesting on
the screen it could just be to make them
you know and that's what makes the
character special and unique right it's
not just another killer it's a killer
who loves bowling so that sets yours up
from different one of like if hey do you
want to see this film about a killer who
was just wearing a suit looks like a
Quentin Tarantino ripoff or do you want
to see one who's the bowling guy was
wearing a bowling shirt it's like I'd
rather watch the bowling shirt guy that
seems different I haven't seen that
before and maybe the bowling ball will
come in and play later on or maybe it
won't maybe you'll just be a shirt he's
wearing right right and maybe he has
like this bowling bag and you think it's
his shoes and he's keeping them
meticulous but it's really whatever he
is he's hiding and so
yeah we've just made a short film
hell so you're saying we don't
necessarily go into a long backstory of
course because we don't have time but
there'll be little things that'll
signify that could make it more Rich you
know and that's what we want too we want
things that are special and unique and
have depth to it and that's why I do
think when you go back to see older
short films the ones that stand out have
all those layers and have all this
unique elements to it and are
interesting and are not just generic you
know we're crossing off these points to
make this happen in seven minutes look
we did it okay good congratulations you
did and that's hard I don't mean to
dismiss that it is hard to make a good
story that works in seven minutes but
you know we're not necessarily going to
stand up and give you a round of
applause just because you did it
ten thousand people submitted short
films to the Sundance Film Festival last
year 10 000 people did it
it's not so much anymore like you get a
ribbon because you did it
um a lot of people are making short
films so you want to make something
that's so special and unique it was
worth your time and worth your effort
and with your money and worth everybody
else's effort of putting all this time
into it so put as much as you can also
you know sometimes you're not ready to
shoot yet so now why not wait while
you're waiting for to get enough money
to shoot or get the right people to
shoot spend that time doing backstories
and developing things more and you know
figuring out to make a set more unique
and you know
put it all in there put everything you
want to do under there but just don't
waste time on it and storytelling time
sure and you had mentioned uh music
videos previously do you think that
storytelling currently with music videos
has gotten better or worse well for a
long time music videos were almost
stories all the time right that they
would either build something into it and
then have the music video be just a
little part of it and continue on
um but like Beyonce she's just music
stories that uh and they've shown her
stuff in film festivals um and quite
often there's a beginning middle and end
in the story that she's doing and quite
often um her music videos are heavily
influenced by other films that exist so
she's taken and um you know she and her
director she doesn't direct them all
um you know synthesize all these
elements that are influenced and have
put out visual albums and visual
storytelling
um and uh I used to program short films
by women at the American Cinema Tech and
we would always like to include a music
video because that's another way that
directors direct through music videos
and there were it was very often very
easy to find a music video that actually
had narrative storytelling in it
sometimes they weren't like lip syncing
along to the music the music was kind of
in the background
um but you know they're very expensive
music videos that are made that are
literally short films and and more power
to them it makes them interesting and
not you know your standards
performance somebody's just standing on
the stage and we've captured it